Hi, everyone.
I'm Justin K. Thompson,
and I am the production
designer for Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse.
When we were working
on the animated film,
the most exciting
part of the process
was bringing Miles
Morales to life
on the big screen for the
first time in a way that
had never been seen before.
We knew how special
the character was,
and that we wanted to give
him his own unique style
of animation.
And it's been amazing
to see the way audiences
have responded to the movie.
And now, it's exciting to
see that Insomnia Games
and PlayStation in
collaboration with Marvel Games,
created its own take
on the character
in Marvel's Spider-Man:
Miles Morales,
coming out for PS5 and PS4.
The way Insomniac faithfully
brought the iconic suit
designed for Spider-Man: Into
the Spider-Verse into the game
is visually stunning
and remarkable.
We were able to advise on some
of the unique design elements
that made the film so distinct,
like how we often animated
the characters on twos, and we
made recommendations for how
best to integrate
the pop up words
and the little burst
cards on screen
into the action sequences.
Hey, The Underground's
messing with a billboard.
Just pinged it.
The Underground must
be nearby if they're
hijacking that billboard.
Got to lock on to the
signal so I can find
where the Underground's hiding.
Locking on.
All right.
Now to track them down.
The Underground's trying to get
the press to notice them more.
Maybe they should launch an ad.
The Underground, as advertised.
UNDERGROUND: Do you
think anyone's--
How's building that
Underground brand going?
UNDERGROUND: I'll show
you what we can do!
UNDERGROUND: You
can't even see him!
UNDERGROUND: Take him down!
UNDERGROUND: Can't wait
to rip that mask off!
You won't stop us!
This your warning-- go home!
Take your best shot!
It won't--
There's gotta be a
transmitter around here.
Friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man-- one.
Underground advertising
campaign-- zero.
Something's weakening emergency
responder communications.
Should check it out.
Spider-Man, thank god.
Something's weakening
our emergency comms.
We can't get through
to the fire department.
Is anyone still inside?
No, we got everyone out.
But this fire's going to
jump if we don't get help.
Hear that?
Just noise now.
I think I can find the source.
Don't worry.
I'm going to get
your comms back up.
The sooner I get to
the source, the sooner
the fire trucks get here.
My webs can't handle
a fire this big.
Whatever is weakening
the signal is just ahead.
Fire's burning real good,
and all I'm hearing is static.
Guess powering down
the tower worked.
Insurance only pays out if
the whole building goes down.
So make sure the
static stays till then.
They're weakening comms
for an insurance scam?
Got to stop them.
CRIMINAL: Hey, you sure you
know what you're doing there?
CRIMINAL: Yeah, I watched
one of those video tutorials.
Seriously, there's one for
everything on the internet.
CRIMINAL: Oh, don't show up.
CRIMINAL: I hate
New York winters.
I haven't felt my
toes in a week.
CRIMINAL: Payday is going
to be sweet on this one.
CRIMINAL: You know it.
Just gotta wait a
little while longer.
Sorry guys.
You really should've gone
for the Spider-Man insurance.
Comms are weak because
there's no power.
I need to charge
up that generator.
Hey Mr. EMT.
Dudes are trying to
burn down that building
for an insurance scam.
That's why they're
messing with your comms.
EMT: Are you serious?
They're putting
people in danger.
Yeah.
How's the fire looking?
EMT: It's getting real close to
jumping the building next door.
And I still can't reach
the fire department.
Signal should be clear soon.
Hang tight.
I'll update you.
Getting close.
CRIMINAL: Hang on.
The signal's stronger now.
What did you do?
CRIMINAL: Why are you always
assuming things are my fault?
Huh?
What's that about?
Can't wait.
I've got to get those
comms back to normal.
CRIMINAL: Kind of feeling a
little bad for the neighbors.
What if the fire spreads?
CRIMINAL: You must be new here.
CRIMINAL: Spider-Man!
Whoever takes him
out gets a bonus!
CRIMINAL: He just
freakin' vanished!
He's over here!
CRIMINAL: Stay out of
my business freak show!
CRIMINAL: He's mine!
CRIMINAL: Any luck with this?
CRIMINAL: This ain't
gonna end well for you.
Now to get the comms
back to full power.
There.
Think that worked.
I should check on the fire and
make sure comms are back up.
Hey, how's the signal now?
EMT: Everything is coming
through loud and clear.
Got through to dispatch too.
Fire trucks are pulling up now.
Fire department
got the building
extinguished just in time.
I'm definitely giving
your app five stars.
Glad I could help.
Spread the word, too.
The more people use the app,
the safer we'll make New York.
I'm going to make sure
everybody knows about it.
Thanks again, Spider-Man.
Mom was right.
Neighborhood's gorgeous.
I myself am a huge
fan of comic books.
So I'm excited that
fans like me will get
the opportunity to
play a game with Miles
Morales in the lead role.
Thank you to Insomniac,
our friends at PlayStation,
and Marvel Games for inviting
me to be a part of this video.
We can't wait to see
it all come together.
ANNOUNCER: PlayStation.